[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen zu 10
Minuten Nachrichten natürlich auch mit
Sport von Norbert König ja guten Abend
und wir schauen wie das Kabinett seine
Konflikte lösen will
auf der Suche nach Harmonie in Klausur
auf Schloss Meseberg versucht die
zerstrittene Ampelkoalition sich wieder
zusammen zu raufen
[Musik]
für den Zukunftsplan beim Volkskongress
in China erfahren 3000 Delegierte dass
ihre Führung unter anderem massiv
aufrüsten will
und es geht wieder rund die Formel 1
startet den bachraine die neue Saison
und wie das Weltmeister schneller als
alle anderen
beim Geld hört der Spaß auf das ist auch
eine Ampelkoalition so da streiten sich
SPD Grüne und FDP gleich um mehrere
Themen denn zur Zeit laufen die
Verhandlungen für den Haushalt
Kompromisse sollen bei der zweitägigen
Kabinettsklausur auf Schloss Meseberg
gefunden werden die heute begonnen hat
vor allem Grüne und FDP haben sich
verhakt zum Beispiel beim Klimaschutz
gestritten wird hier vor allem über den
schnelleren Ausbau von Infrastruktur und
das Aus für Verbrennungsmotoren ab 2.35
und schreit gibt es auch in der
Sozialpolitik über die Finanzierung der
Kindergrundsicherung Patricia Wiedemeier
berichtet
immer wieder mal zieht sich die
Bundesregierung in die Idylle von
Schloss Meseberg nördlich von Berlin
zurück hier wurde man in Ruhe
grundsätzliche Fragen besprechen wie zum
Beispiel die Transformation der
Industrie so Bundeskanzler Scholz wir
werden zunächst einmal darüber reden wie
eine Gesellschaft die so viel vor sich
hat zuversichtlich sein kann und bleiben
kann zum Auftakt gab es ein rund zwei
stündiges Gespräch mit
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
über den Ukraine Krieg und seine Folgen
aber auch über gemeinsame
Herausforderungen
selbstverständlich ist die wichtigste
Frage wie kriegen wir das hin den
Menschen gemacht und Klimawandel
aufzuhalten
das ist unsere Perspektive damit sind
viele Umbrüche verbunden wir müssen viel
tun aber wir haben auch viel zu bieten
das sollten wir nie vergessen wir haben
den größten Binnenmarkt der Welt wir
haben exzellente Unternehmen die globale
Technologieführer sind wir haben ein
fachkräfterreservoir das seinesgleichen
weltweit sucht die Streitthemen und
davon gibt es derzeit viele stehen
offiziell nicht auf der Tagesordnung zum
Beispiel die Finanzierung der Kinder
Grundsicherung beschleunigte Planungen
im Verkehrsbereich oder die Zukunft des
verbrennermotors es sind vor allem Grüne
und FDP die sich streiten mehr Geld für
neue Schulden wird es nicht geben stellt
Finanzminister Lindner klar im nächsten
Jahr muss die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
werden ohne Rücklagen ohne
Steuererhöhung und bei steigenden Zinsen
da muss nun priorisiert werden auch wenn
der Kanzler sich demonstrativ gut
gelaunt gibt dies angesichts all der
schwierigen Themen von Dauer ist
fraglich
ja und alle Konfliktpunkte werden wohl
nicht gelöst werden
wie wichtig ist dieses Treffen für die
zerstrittene Koalition
das Treffen ist wichtig auch weil der
inhaltliche Streit mittlerweile zu einer
ziemlichen Gereiztheit geführt hat
Robert Habeck wird grummelnd aus dem
Kabinett zitiert der Vertrauensvorschuss
sei jetzt aufgebraucht und all die
Punkte über die man aktuell streitet
sind für die jeweiligen Parteien
natürlich wichtig nicht zuletzt um sich
bei den eigenen Wählern zu profilieren
und das Geld ist auch kriegsbedingt sehr
viel knapper als anfangs gedacht ein
bequemes sowohl als auch lässt sich
jetzt nicht mehr finanzieren das
vergangene Jahr war kriegst dominiert
jetzt aber wollen die ampelparteien ihre
jeweiligen politischen Punkte machen und
das zeigt wie groß die politischen
Unterschiede sind der Kanzler möchte von
der Klausur ein Zeichen der Zuversicht
für die Menschen senden das dürfte
mindestens mal auch für seine Koalition
Geld gelten danke für die Einschätzung
Naturschutzorganisation bewerten das
neue unabkommen zum Schutz der Hochzeit
positiv von einem Tag zum Jubeln spricht
der WWF Greenpeace nennt die Einigung
historisch künftig sollen mindestens 30%
der Welt mehr als Schutzgebiete
ausgewiesen werden bei wirtschaftlichen
Projekten oder Expeditionen auf hoher
See wird geprüft ob sie
umweltverträglich sind
schauen wir nach China dort hat heute
der Nationale Volkskongress begonnen
also das jährliche Treffen der rund 3000
Abgeordneten china will nach den
strikten corona-lockdowns die Wirtschaft
wieder richtig zum laufen kriegen zudem
sollen die Verteidigungsausgaben weiter
steigen mehr zum polit-spektakel in der
chinesischen Hauptstadt von Miriam
Steimer
rund um den tierenplatz in Peking ist
nicht zu übersehen dass heute das größte
politische Ereignis des Jahres beginnt
in der großen Halle des Volkes trifft
sich Chinas scheinparlament um die
Entscheidungen abzunicken die die
Parteiführung längst gefällt hat zum
Beispiel das wirtschaftsziel für dieses
Jahr rund 5% Wachstum strebt das Land an
nach dem Ende der Null corbit-politik
soll es endlich wieder nach oben gehen
der scheidende Ministerpräsident sendet
auch eine Botschaft an Taiwan
wir sollten die friedliche
Wiedervereinigung von Taiwan mit dem
Mutterland vorantreiben wie Chinesen auf
beiden Seiten der Taiwanstraße sind eine
Familie durch Blut verbunden
seit Jahren spricht Peking von
Wiedervereinigung sieht das
demokratische Taiwan als abtrünnige
Provinz dabei gehörte Taiwan nie zur
heutigen Volksrepublik für China ist die
Insel aber ein Grund seine
Militärausgaben zu erhöhen
Fernbedienung vor allem ihre
Kampfbereitschaft soll die Armee
verbessern dafür erhöht China den
Militäretat um
7,2%. doch das ist nur ein Teil der
wirklichen Ausgaben viele Aufwendungen
werden zusätzlich aus anderen Etats
gedeckt
der Taktgeber des Volkskongresses ist
der Delegierte mit der Nummer 0642
Parteichef zieht den pingen baut seine
Macht weiter aus und lässt sich das hier
absegnen er wird sich seine historische
Tritte Amtszeit als Präsident bestätigen
lassen für seine Vorgänger war nach
zweimal fünf Jahren Schluss
[Musik]
in Israel gibt es weiter Widerstand
gegen die Justizreform der
rechtsreligiösen Regierung von
Ministerpräsidenten tanjao landesweit
protestierten gestern rund 250.000
Menschen in Tel Aviv gab es auch
vereinzelt Ausschreitungen und
Festnahmen im Kern geht es bei der
Justizreform darum Entscheidungen des
höchsten Gerichts mit einfacher Mehrheit
im Parlament aufzuheben schon im April
könnten Teile der Reform umgesetzt
werden
in Offenburg im Baden-Württemberg hat es
am Rande eines landesparteitages der AFD
schwere Ausschreitungen gegeben nach
Angaben der Polizei wurden mehr als 50
Polizisten verletzt als sie gewalttätige
afd-gegner von einer friedlichen
Demonstration trennen wollten viele
Beamte hätten Prellungen und
Atemwegsreizungen erlitten die
Initiatoren der Demo distanzierten sich
von den Gewalttätern
ja wir kommen zum Sport die neue Formel
1-Saison hat begonnen und der
Weltmeister ist ja schon wieder vorne
und zwar direkt auch mit komfortablen
Vorsprung 12 Sekunden schneller als sein
Teamkollege Sergio Perez ist
Titelverteidiger Max vestappen beim
Saison Auftakt in Bachrain Mann des
Tages aber wird Altmeister Fernando
Alonso auf Platz 3
der kam gar nicht mehr raus aus dem
feiermodus mit 41 Jahren wieder auf dem
Podest das war ein zuletzt von 9 Jahren
im Ferrari gelungen und so spielt der
Spanier dem Souverän in Weltmeister und
tages-sieger Max Verstappen die Show das
tappen fährt bis auf einen Boxenstopp
immer vorneweg Schale clair muss an
Position drei liegen mit
hydraulikproblemen aufgeben Glück gehört
dem tüchtigen Alonso sieht seine Chance
er zieht mit seinem ersten Martin am
zweiten Ferrari Piloten Carlos Seins
vorbei erobert Platz 3 Nico Hülkenberg
verliert den positionskampf ein
frontflügelteil und fällt von Rang 10
zurück wird 15 dominierend aber sind die
Red Bull fast abentester Perez 2
das erste Sonntagsspiel der Bundesliga
gewinnt Leverkusen gegen Hertha BSC mit
vier zu eins und verbessert sich auf
Platz 9 Hertha bleibt 14 nur ein Punkt
besser als das schlussquartett Stuttgart
Hoffenheim Schalke und Bochum die
Deutschen handball-nationalspielerinnen
haben in Heidelberg das drei
Länderturnier gewonnen nach dem sie
gestern gegen Ungarn gelingt heute ein
32 zu 30 gegen Polen und im Biathlon hat
Frankreich beim Weltcup in novimiestor
die Mixed-Staffel gewonnen zu oft
daneben schoss das deutsche Quartett
eine Strafrunde und 13 nach Lader
bringen Platz 4 hinter Frankreich und
Schweden wird Norwegen nur Dritter die
müllbrüder waren positiv auf Corona
getestet worden
das wars
und so wird das Wetter viele wollten nur
im Nordosten und äußersten Süden lockert
es gebietsweise auf dazu fällt über der
Mitte zeitweise Regen und Schnee von
Niedersachsen bis nach Brandenburg auch
kräftiger bei 1 bis 7 Grad
um 21:45 Uhr können Sie es heute journal
mit Marietta Slomka sehen im Interview
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner Morgen
begrüßt Sie an dieser Stelle mit Siren